Let's go next to I think I'm pronouncing it
correctly, is it Alida or Alida?
Yes, it's Alida.
How are you Alida?
I'm good.
I can't believe I'm talking to you.
I watch you every day.
Thank you.
My question to you is in regards to the voter
suppression bill in Georgia.
Yes, of course, there's been something like
two hundred and fifty three other legislations
going to all 50 states.
Yep.
Is there something?
If they don't get it resolved, is there something
that Joe Biden, Joe Biden can do to override
these voter suppression laws?
I don't know that there's anything Biden can
do, but there is much that the House and Senate
can do.
And there is currently a bill that would enshrine
certain voter enfranchisement, voting rights
protections.
It's unclear whether that's going to pass.
I think that this is this is not something
Biden can do directly, but it's certainly
something the House and Senate can do in a
way that would create a framework that all
states have to meet certain guidelines and
states wouldn't be able to go beyond or ignore
some of these federal election guidelines.
So that would be that's the path forward,
I think.
OK, in order to do that, they would have to
get rid of the filibuster.
You think that's a good question?
I mean, listen, I think I don't know the answer.
I, I would like to think there's a way to
get it through the Senate without blowing
up the filibuster.
But, yeah, I mean, you're definitely on to
something.
It's conceivable that the filibuster would
need to be done away with to pass that.
Yeah, that that's that's quite a possibility.
OK, well, thank you so much, David.
My pleasure.
Great to speak to you.
It's good to speak to you to have a good day.
You, too, Alida.
Perfect phone call, I would say.